De hecho, algunos pensaban que causaba una sensibilidad exacerbada
y que confería genio creativo.
En la década de los cincuenta,
descubrimos, en cambio, que la tuberculosis era causada
por una infección bacteriana altamente contagiosa,
lo cual no era tan romántico,
pero tenía la ventaja
de que, tal vez, pudiéramos desarrollar medicamentos para tratarla.
Los doctores descubrieron una nueva medicina: iproniazida,
la cual, creían, podría curar la tuberculosis.
Se la dieron a los pacientes,
y los pacientes se sentían eufóricos;
se volvieron más sociales, más enérgicos.
De hecho, un reporte médico decía que "bailaban por los pasillos".
Desafortunadamente,
esto no significaba que estuvieran mejorando:
muchos de ellos seguían muriendo.
Otro informe médico los describía como "inapropiadamente felices".
Así fue como se descubrió el primer antidepresivo.
Los descubrimientos accidentales no son poco comunes en la ciencia,
pero se requiere más que solo un accidente feliz;
Se debe ser capaz de reconocerlo para que éste ocurra.
Como neurocientífica, les hablaré un poco
de mi experiencia personal
con lo que conocemos como opuesto a la suerte casual,
yo le llamo suerte inteligente.
Pero antes, un poco más de historia.
Afortunadamente, desde la década de los cincuentas,
hemos desarrollado otros medicamentos y ahora podemos curar la tuberculosis.
Al menos en EE. UU., quizá no en otros países,
cerramos nuestros sanatorios
quizá a la mayoría de Uds. no les preocupe mucho la tuberculosis.
Lo que se creía a principios del siglo XX
sobre las enfermedades infecciosas,
se puede aplicar en la actualidad a los trastornos psiquiátricos.
Hoy existe una epidemia de trastornos emocionales,
como la depresión y el trastorno de estrés postraumático, TEPT.
Uno de cada cuatro de todos los adultos en EE. UU.
sufre una enfermedad mental,
lo que significa que si no lo has experimentado
o nadie en tu familia,
es muy probable que alguien que conozcas lo sufra,
aunque no se hable de ello.
En la actualidad, la depresión superó
al VIH/SIDA, a la malaria, a la diabetes y a la guerra,
y es la principal causa de discapacidad a nivel mundial.
Como con la tuberculosis en los cincuenta,
no sabemos cuáles son sus causas.
Una vez que se desarrolla es crónico,
dura toda la vida y no hay cura conocida.
El segundo antidepresivo se descubrió
también por accidente, en los cincuentas,
de un antihistamínico que volvía maníacos a los pacientes,
fue la imipramina.
Tanto en los pabellones de tuberculosis como con el antihistamínico,
alguien fue capaz de reconocer
que una medicina desarrollada para un fin,
tratar la tuberculosis o combatir alergias,
podría utilizarse para algo completamente diferente:
tratar la depresión.
Este tipo de readaptación es bastante desafiante.
Cuando los doctores notaron el efecto de la iproniazida en el estado de ánimo,
al principio no lograron reconocerlo.
Pensaban que ese medicamento
solo servía para tratar la tuberculosis,
y solo lo catalogaron como un efecto secundario adverso.
Como pueden ver aquí,
muchos de estos pacientes en 1954 experimentaban una euforia severa
y les preocupaba que eso pudiera interferir de algún modo
con su recuperación de la tuberculosis.
Solo recomendaban el uso de la iproniazida en casos extremos de TB,
y en pacientes que fueran muy estables emocionalmente,
lo cual es exactamente lo contrario de su uso como antidepresivo
Veían al medicamento desde la perspectiva de esta enfermedad,
que no pudieron ver su relación con la otra enfermedad.
Siendo justos, no fue del todo culpa suya.
La inflexibilidad funcional nos afecta a todos.
Es la tendencia a pensar en un objeto
solo en términos de su uso o función tradicional.
Los patrones mentales son distintos,
son una estructura preconcebida
para enfrentar los problemas.
Y eso hace que readaptar sea bastante difícil
por eso le dieron un programa de TV
al tipo que era muy bueno para la readaptación.
(Risas)
Los efectos en los dos casos: en la iproniazida como el la imipramina,
eran muy fuertes,
había manía o gente bailando en los pasillos.
No es de sorprenderse que se les descubriera.
Pero lo hace pensar a uno en qué más hemos pasado por alto.
Entonces, la iproniazida y la imipramina,
son más que un caso práctico de readaptación.
Tienen dos cosas más en común que son muy importantes.
Una, tienen efectos secundarios terribles.
Estos incluyen toxicidad hepática,
aumento de peso de más de 20 kg,
tendencias suicidas.
Y dos, ambos aumentan los niveles de serotonina,
que es una señal química en el cerebro,
o un neurotransmisor.
Y esas dos cosas juntas,
la primera o la segunda pueden no ser tan importantes,
pero juntas significaba que debíamos hacer medicinas más seguras,
y que la serotonina parecía ser un buen punto de partida.
Así que elaboramos medicinas enfocadas en la serotonina, específicamente,
los ISRS, o inhibidores selectivos de la recaptación de serotonina,
de los cuales Prozac es el más famoso.
Eso fue hace 30 años,
y desde entonces hemos trabajado casi en solo optimizar esas medicinas.
Los ISRS, son mejores que las medicinas anteriores,
pero aún tienen muchos efectos secundarios,
incluyendo aumento de peso, insomnio,
tendencias suicidas,
y tardan mucho tiempo en hacer efecto, entre 4 y 6 semanas en muchos pacientes.
Y eso en los pacientes con quienes sí funcionan.
En muchos pacientes estas medicinas no funcionan.
Esto significa que hoy, en el 2016,
todavía no existen curas para ningún trastorno emocional,
solo hay medicinas que inhiben los síntomas.
que es como la diferencia entre tomar un analgésico para una infección
en lugar de un antibiótico.
El analgésico les hará sentir mejor,
pero no hará nada para curar esa enfermedad subyacente.
Este pensar con flexibilidad nos ayudó a reconocer
que la imipramina y la iproniazida podían ser readaptadas así,
así llegamos a la hipótesis de la serotonina, con la que luego,
irónicamente, nos obsesionamos.
Estas son señales cerebrales, serotonina,
de un comercial de ISRS.
Por si no está claro, esto es una dramatización.
En la ciencia, intentamos suprimir nuestro prejuicio,
realizando experimentos doble ciego,
o siendo estadísticamente agnósticos sobre nuestros resultados.
Pero, insidiosamente, los prejuicios se asoman en lo que elegimos estudiar
y en la manera en que elegimos estudiarlo.
Entonces, nos enfocamos en la serotonina, durante los últimos 30 años,
a menudo excluyendo otras cosas.
Todavía no tenemos curas.
¿Y si la serotonina no es lo único que existe para la depresión?
¿Y si no es ni siquiera la parte clave?
Esto significa que sin importar cuánto tiempo,
dinero o esfuerzo pongamos en eso,
nunca nos llevará a la cura.
En los últimos años, los doctores han descubierto
probablemente el primer antidepresivo realmente nuevo desde los ISRS,
el Calypsol.
Esta medicina funciona muy rápido, en cuestión de horas o en un día,
y no afecta la serotonina.
Tiene efecto sobre el glutamato, que es otro neurotransmisor.
Y también se readaptó.
Tradicionalmente, se utilizaba como anestesia en cirugía.
Pero a diferencia de otras medicinas,
que fueron descubiertas relativamente rápido,
nos tomó 20 años
para descubrir que el Calypsol era un antidepresivo,
pese al hecho que tal vez sea mejor antidepresivo
que esos otros medicamentos.
Probablemente por el hecho de ser un mejor antidepresivo,
se nos hizo más difícil de identificar.
No había manía que indicara sus efectos.
En el 2013, en la Universidad de Columbia,
estaba trabajando con mi colega,
la Dra. Christine Ann Denny,
estudiando el Calypsol como antidepresivo en ratones.
El Calypsol tiene una vida media realmente corta,
lo que significa que nuestro cuerpo lo desecha en pocas horas.
Solo lo estábamos probando.
Le administrábamos una inyección a los ratones
y esperábamos una semana.
Luego hacíamos otro experimento para economizar.
Y en uno de los experimentos,
indujimos estrés en los ratones
y utilizamos eso como modelo de depresión.
Al principio parecía no funcionar en absoluto.
Hubiéramos podido detenernos ahí.
Pero había utilizado este modelo de depresión por años,
y los datos lucían algo raros.
No me parecían correctos.
Así que regresamos
y reanalizamos el experimento,
basándonos en si se les inyectó Calypsol a los ratones
una semana antes.
El experimento fue algo así.
Miren el primer cuadro de la izquierda,
si se pone un ratón en un espacio nuevo,
esta es la caja, es muy interesante,
el ratón dará vueltas y explorará.
Como pueden ver, esa línea rosa es la medida de lo que caminaban.
También pusimos otro ratón en un portalápiz
con el que podía elegir interactuar.
Esta también es una dramatización, por si no está claro.
Un ratón normal exploraría,
sería sociable.
Observen lo que pasa.
Si se induce estrés al ratón, en este modelo de depresión,
que es el recuadro de en medio,
no son sociables, no exploran.
Tienden más a esconderse en la esquina trasera, detrás del portalápiz.
Sin embargo, los ratones que recibieron una inyección de Calypsol,
los de la derecha,
exploraban y socializaban.
Parecían no haber estado estresados nunca,
lo cual es imposible.
Pudimos haber parado ahí,
pero Christine también había usado Calypsol antes como anestesia,
y hace algunos años había visto
que parecía tener efectos extraños en las células y en otros comportamientos
que también parecían durar mucho después de la medicina,
quizá hasta unas semanas.
Pensamos, está bien,
quizá no sea totalmente imposible,
pero estábamos muy escépticas.
Hicimos lo que haces en la ciencia
cuando no estás seguro: lo repetimos de nuevo.
Recuerdo estar en la sala de experimentos,
moviendo ratones de una caja a otra para evaluarlos,
y Christine estaba sentada en el piso con la computadora en su regazo
para que los ratones no la vieran,
estaba analizando la información en tiempo real.
Me acuerdo que gritamos,
lo que no se debe hacer en la sala de experimentos en una prueba,
porque había funcionado.
Parecía como si estos ratones estuvieran protegidos contra el estrés
estaban inapropiadamente felices, como quieran llamarlo.
Estábamos muy entusiasmadas
pero también muy escépticas
Era demasiado bueno pare ser cierto.
Así que lo hicimos nuevamente.
Y luego otra vez en un modelo de TEPT,
y una vez más en un modelo fisiológico,
donde solo les dimos hormonas de estrés
Se lo asignamos a los alumnos.
Luego dejamos que nuestros colaboradores,
al otro lado del mundo en Francia lo ejecutaran.
Y cada vez que lo hacían se confirmaba lo mismo.
Parecía que una inyección de Calypsol
los protegía del estrés por semanas.
Se publicó solo hace un año, desde entonces,
otros laboratorios han confirmado este efecto independientemente.
No sabemos qué causa la depression
pero sí sabemos que el estrés es la causa inicial,
en 80% de los casos.
La depresión y el TEPT
son enfermedades distintas pero tienen algo en común:
el estrés traumático,
como en el combate activo, o en desastres naturales,
o la violencia comunitaria, o las agresiones sexuales,
eso es lo que origina el trastorno de estrés postraumático.
No todos los que sufren estrés desarrollan un trastorno emocional.
La habilidad de sufrir estrés y ser fuertes
y de recuperarse y no desarrollar depresión o TEPT
es conocida como resistencia al estrés,
y varía entre las personas.
Siempre habíamos pensamos que era un tipo de cualidad pasiva.
Es la ausencia de factores de susceptibilidad
y de riesgo para estos trastornos.
¿Pero, y si estuviera activa?
Tal vez podríamos mejorarla,
algo parecido a ponernos una armadura.
Hemos descubierto por accidente
el primer medicamento que mejora la resistencia.
Y como dije, solo les dimos una pequeña cantidad del medicamento,
y duró semanas,
y eso no es lo que se ve con los antidepresivos.
De hecho, se parece a lo que se ve con las vacunas.
Con las vacunas, recibes la dosis,
y después de semanas, meses y años,
cuando te expones a la bacteria,
no es la vacuna en tu cuerpo lo que te protege.
Es tu sistema inmunológico,
que ha desarrollado resistencia,
y que combate la bacteria,
y, de hecho, nunca te infectas.
Lo cual es muy diferente a nuestros tratamientos, ¿no?
En ese caso, contraes la infección, estás expuesto a la bacteria,
te enfermas, y tomas un antibiótico que te cura
y esas medicinas actúan, de hecho, matando a la bacteria.
O similar a lo que dije antes sobre el paliativo,
se toma algo que inhibe los síntomas,
pero no trata la infección subyacente,
y solo te sentirás mejor durante el tiempo que lo tomes,
y por eso necesitas seguir tomándolo.
En la depresión y en el TEPT,
aquí tenemos al estrés como factor de riesgo,
solo existe el tratamiento paliativo.
Los antidepresivos solo inhiben los síntomas,
y es por eso que debes continuar tomando la medicina
mientras dure la enfermedad,
que a menudo coincide con la duración de tu propia vida.
Así que nombramos a nuestra medicina para mejorar la resistencia "paravacunas",
que significa: similar a una vacuna,
porque parece que pueden tener el potencial
de proteger contra el estrés
y evitar que los "ratones" desarrollen
depresión o trastorno de estrés postraumático.
Pero no todos los antidepresivos son también paravacunas
También probamos con Prozac
y no tuvo efecto.
Entonces si trasladamos esto a humanos,
podríamos ser capaces de proteger a personas
que estén previsiblemente en riesgo
de trastornos inducidos por el estrés como la depresión y el TEPT.
O sea, para personal en emergencias y bomberos,
refugiados, presos y guardias de prisión,
soldados, etc.
Para darles una idea de la magnitud de estas enfermedades,
en el 2010, la carga global de enfermedades
se estimó en 2.5 billones de dólares,
y dado que son crónicas,
el costo se agravará, y se espera que aumente a seis billones
en solo los próximos 15 años.
Como dije anteriormente,
la readaptación puede ser desafiante debido a nuestros prejuicios.
El Calypsol tiene otro nombre:
Ketamine
conocida también como "Special K",
es una droga recreativa y de abuso.
Aún se utiliza en todo el mundo como anestesia.
Se usa en niños y en campos de batalla.
De hecho, es la medicina de preferencia en muchos de los países en desarrollo,
porque no afecta la respiración.
Está en la lista de la Organización Mundial de la Salud
de los medicamentos más importantes.
Si hubiéramos descubierto primero la ketamina como paravacuna,
nos sería bastante fácil desarrollarla.
Pero tal como es, tenemos que luchar con nuestra inflexibilidad funcional,
y nuestros patrones mentales que interfieren.
Afortunadamente, no es el único compuesto que hemos descubierto
que tiene características profilácticas y paravacunas.
Todas las otras medicinas,
o compuestos que hemos descubierto
son completamente nuevos.
Deben pasar por todo el proceso de aprobación de la FDA,
si es que lo pasan, antes de que se puedan usar en humanos.
Y eso puede tomar años.
Así que si queríamos algo más pronto,
la ketamina ya estaba aprobada por la FDA.
Es un medicamento genérico que está a la venta.
La podríamos desarrollar por una fracción del precio y en poco tiempo.
Más allá de la inflexibilidad funcional y los patrones mentales
existe otro desafío para la readaptación de las medicinas,
o sea, la política.
No existen incentivos disponibles,
una vez que una medicina es genérica, sin patente y deja de ser exclusiva,
que alienten a las compañías de fármacos
a desarrollarlas porque no producen dinero.
Y esto no es válido solo para la ketamina; aplica para todos los medicamentos.
De todas formas, la idea en sí es completamente nueva en la psiquiatría,
el utilizar medicinas para prevenir trastornos mentales
en vez de solo tratarlos.
Es posible que en 20, 50 o 100 años,
miremos hacia atrás y pensemos en la depresión y el TEPT
igual que lo hacemos con los sanatorios de tuberculosis,
como algo del pasado.
Este podría ser el principio del fin de la epidemia de trastornos mentales.
Pero como dijo una vez un gran científico:
"Sólo un tonto está seguro de algo, un hombre sabio continúa adivinando".
Gracias a todos.
(Aplausos).